[Music]
no one else will defend the walk than I
must
well Wonder Woman had Cedars a week from
today but last night the stars turned
out for the big LA premiere now gal
gadot amazing in this movie especially
when you consider that she was five
months pregnant when they were shooting
it her maybes two months old now so ma I
got a rare night out when you leave the
house tonight do you say to Maya uh bye
Maya mommy's gonna go be a superhero now
I know I tried to keep it simple Lauri
like I'm gonna go to work part of
keeping it simple wearing flats with
that red sequin chivonne she dress
that's mainly because gal recently hurt
her back I'm in bed because I threw my
back out - whose house your back you
need some attention but I'm sure the
ones we're done with the mayhem then
we're gonna have time to relax there was
mayhem last night all right
especially when Lynda Carter the
original Wonder Woman arrived you are
the mayor of the gorge yes I am the
bearer of the torch and now I'm passing
it forward I really want you all to
embrace this embrace this like you
embraced me with these costumes fans
were definitely embracing their new
heroes last night it's incredible I mean
this guy over here as an outfit II just
made it's incredible
there should be like an award show just
for the costumes today
it's off the chain man these off the
chain as an adjective see you're
learning oh man you're learning this is
a movie - grab your girlfriend and go
see it's just that good now we will be
seeing gallon full Wonder Woman mode
twice this year she also has Justice
League hitting theaters on November 17
you